good morning and good afternoon my name
is joe rogers and i work in business
development for the clinical oncology
next generation sequencing division at
thermal fissure scientific
on behalf of thermo fisher scientific
and my colleagues who develop and
support
the ngs based tools for improved
oncology profiling i would like to thank
you
welcome you to our educational program
entitled changing the precision oncology
research paradigm
today's event is intended to provide
attendees with a high level
understanding
of the decision-making process in
bringing ngs-based oncology testing
in-house
from a pathologist and administrative
perspective as well as give you an
insightful view on the ease of use and
overall effectiveness of the genexis
platform
to accomplish this goal i want to thank
you all in attendance for your time
today
and would you please complete the poll
at the conclusion of the presentations
with that i would like to introduce dr
eric bale to discuss the importance of
getting clinical research
results as fast as possible impacted qns
and related case studies dr vale is
currently the director of molecular
pathology
at cedars-sinai medical center
responsible for the administration
development and validation of all
clinical molecular diagnostics at
cedars-sinai
dr vale received his md from st george's
university
in 2017 he completed his apcp residency
at new york medical college
and subsequently finished a molecular
genetic pathology fellow
cedar sinai dr vale's primary research
focus is in the utilization
of clinical resequencing in cancer and
more recently the local genomics of sars
kovi 2.
dr vale thank you very much for joining
us
hey good morning everybody uh my name is
uh eric vale i am the director of
molecular pathology
here at uh cedars-sinai medical center
and before covid i actually did a lot of
oncology
um uh the uh just a quick disclosure
uh uh thermo fisher and it's phillies
don't
employ me they're not endorsing anything
that we were saying here
and uh i was not providing any uh
i was provided a monetary enumeration
for this presentation
um i just give a quick uh outline
of what we're gonna talk about today is
sort of
the benefits of uh clinical next
generation sequencing
and some of the drawbacks with the
ever-expanding
rise and biomarkers uh we're seeing
uh really a need to do
more testing on on more people so i
really want to see how
important this is this chart is uh
not completely perfect because
clinically relevant biomarkers actually
in oncology started in the mid 80s with
hormone receptors and breast cancer and
selective estrogen receptor modulators
but we generally think of the era of
precision medicine starting a little
later than that with
her2 in breast cancer in
1998 and uh in bcr able
in cml when everybody thought we cured
cancer forever um
and it just ended up turning out to be a
lot more difficult than we
that we ended up predicting in the
beginning um there was a little bit of a
delay
from then into the late 2000s
where egfr and alex started coming out
and then
with lung cancer really leading the way
the last five years have been
an explosion of different biomarkers
and approvals this is a relatively
recent
graph but even it's outdated because of
how quickly things are moving
we have rhett and met already approved
as well
other tumor types are really starting to
come into the fore
with things like homologous
recombination
genes being important for part
inhibitors in multiple different tumor
types
pic3ca in breast cancer
entrec msi being biomarkers that
are pan tumor now so now now it's not
just
uh which tumor type and which which
biomarker but you're having these
biomarkers that can also be
for multiple different tumor types uh
acro across the board so i think
the next kind of thing that's important
is that a lot of these
biomarkers are relatively rare and as we
start discovering more and more of them
as we start getting more and more
indications
we're going to be starting to cut
smaller and smaller pieces of the pie
off
um and so you're getting situations
where things like entrec where you know
sub 0.1 percent pan tumor
and it is exceptionally difficult to do
that
in a way that's efficient unless you're
doing something like sequencing
so in the past most biomarkers were
detected by
single gene uh assays uh these were you
know your ihc
your fish your little specific pcr uh
they're great tests they do an amazing
job for what they do they're highly
specific
but in general they provide limited
information of course they're just a
single gene test
right and as we move away
from one two biomarkers in a tumor
um we're finding that you need to do
more and more and more of these tests to
be able to have a complete analysis
this increased amount of tests now all
of a sudden these
cheap uh relatively tissue sparing
assays start to become a burden
you need uh five six seven eight
tests now for for lung cancer if you're
gonna do everything that's recommended
in a single gene fashion
and this increases cost obviously
and and tissue requirements as well in
an
era where we're having smaller and
smaller and smaller tissue
this is where sequencing comes in so
next generation sequencing the
the i think the better name for it is
massively parallel sequencing it's much
more descriptive it actually says
what it does basically you're sequencing
huge amounts
of uh of genetic material all in
parallel
all at the same time and for
what your the amount of information that
you're receiving
it is exceptionally cheap everyone's
seen that graph
essentially of the cost per base as it
shoots down
and for what you get again it's
much quicker as well the human genome
project
which cost trillions and was
took years and years and years and we're
talking about you know a whole genome in
less than a week and actually if you if
you're a sick infant there's protocols
to get a genome done
in a day um and and
and and to have it relatively cheaply as
well um
sequencing is available commercially and
clinically for
over a decade uh almost i think 2006
2007.
so uh it's in the beginning there were
issues and a lot of
technical expertise that was required in
things like informatics
in the wet lab that
was really hard for the broader
community to be able to adapt
most of those have been significantly
improved on over time
the technology is incredibly reliable
and there's plenty of
commercial applications and a commercial
kits that are available for
people to use on their on their own um
the technical costs are which used to be
astronomical are now uh less than the
analytical costs most of the time
especially if you're doing any sort of
clinical sequencing
and uh it really depends on
the panel size because the bigger
the more amount of stuff that you're
looking at the
more amount of variants you're going to
get that you might know not know what
they are we have
161 gene panel the gene list to the
right
that we currently run for our solid
tumor assay and this i guess would be
considered a medium-sized panel for
for solid tumor testing um
we're thinking of moving to a four five
six hundred gene panel
uh uh currently um and uh
it just they're at a certain point you
start getting more and more of these
things
uh that are difficult to analyze
so uh some of the barriers ngs testing
uh and the ability to adopt it
uh that we're gonna talk about today are
uh
long turnaround time uh limited tissue
high q s rate
staffing constraints and uh
high cost so
uh turnaround time i think is a is a
critical critical one because of
the way that the clinical practice
works around cancer patients and what
the standard of care is
in the first line usually
usually oncologists schedule patients
about
two weeks after they had their procedure
to talk with them about
what their diagnosis is what their uh
treatment course will be what their
prognosis and all that sort of stuff
like that
at that point in time if biomarkers are
going to be used
in a first line therapy they need to be
at and they need to be out in a way
that the oncologist understands them and
can use them
the problem is that sequencing is one of
the longest turnaround time tests of any
test in the laboratory
uh instead of being measured in hours or
possibly a day
uh sequencing is often measured in days
weeks
and used to be even in months
right now clinical sequencing and
oncology is about a week to three weeks
uh and often is measured from receipt
and laboratories so
if you're sending out to a large
reference laboratory uh you know the
patient
oncologist orders they uh the order goes
to the laboratory then they have to
request
and another week goes by before they
even get the tissue so you
add add that on top of that um
critically if the patient was an
inpatient
because of the vagaries of the american
medical medicare and how
how it works there's a 14-day rule that
causes if you do this testing quickly
to fall under the drg where basically
the lab
has to eat the costs as well and so if
you wait for that 14-day rule to be up
then you send out then there's another
14 days for it to be
resulted you're talking about one two
months before that patient has that data
in many tumor types right now that is
not as critical because it's not being
used in the first line therapy
but in things like lung colon
breast these things are becoming more
and more important
and we'll be seeing these actually
become more and more important
across tumors as more of these
biomarkers get approved
for uh therapy so the ability to do
really quick uh relatively broad
sequencing even single day turnaround
time
uh promises to alleviate many of these
issues now you're not really worrying
about that 14-day
rule anymore because you can just go out
and get the weight for that 14 days and
then have
that result out either that's the next
day or the or
or even the same day um so uh
this is one of those things that i think
that in the near future and something
we're going to be talking about later in
some of these presentations
uh is going to be a real game changer in
how we do this sequencing testing
um q s rates
uh so while having fun
you know it used to be really high uh q
a rates are an important consideration
in any assay
many of the almost all of the uh big
reference laboratory panels are your big
500 600 gene panels
that you send that are sent out by
oncologists in the community
are using a hybrid capture based
approach
and while capture probes have gotten
more efficient
and the tissue requirements have gone
down
q s rates at these laboratories are
still in the 15 to 25
range um and you know these assays
require
50 100 nanograms of
nucleic acid if they're doing dna and
rna they require
about the same amount of both
if you use a different type of chemistry
if you use
what we use in our laboratory which is
an amplicon-based library corporation
there are some downsides to that
including
some of the way the data comes out but
what it does is allows you to go quicker
and it allows you to have a
significantly lower
q and s rate so right now our q s rate
last year at cedars was 2.7
um and our assay only required is
listed requiring 20 nanograms of nucleic
acid
we often go down as low as 10 and we've
seen results in some of our prior
platforms and
amplicon-based platforms down as low as
one nanogram of input
nucleic acid that actually produce a
result that had uh
actionable findings i'm not saying that
you're gonna be able to reproduce this
time after time
but uh in uh on occasion you will be
able to get down that low
with uh with with amplicon-based
chemistry
staffing is a huge one now so i had
staffing and costs kind of together and
i kind of separated them out because
they're they're they're they're two
different problems um
and uh staffing really comes down to the
fact that
uh manual ngs preparation is incredibly
uh time-consuming and uh
skilled uh so uh already there's a
national cls shortage uh across the
country
um most programs
that do uh cls training
only have about two to three weeks of
like molecular training if any
uh the vast majority of their training
is in like micro or in
core lab or uh
transfusion uh medicine but uh
the the molecular training is is really
quite lagging so when we end up
hiring somebody you know we spend six
months
uh really going over uh all of their
training and it can
even drag out even longer than that um
you can buy liquid handlers but those
are expensive they usually require high
volume to be at their best efficiency
so if you have low volume it's not
really that not worth it
and uh you need expertise in programming
as well
uh on many of them to use them to their
fullest potential
use them to the ability to uh do
everything that you want without with as
much with as little
uh tech intervention as possible so
if there are systems out there that can
decrease the total amount of tech time
that can increase the amount of
automation without requiring
[Music]
expertise in programming or really high
specimen throughput these are things
that are of huge value
in any laboratory and
we currently have sort of the gamut of
that so
we have uh automation that's good for
high throughput we have automation
that's good for lower throughput
um and almost all of it is essentially
walk away
right now
costs and this is this is you know this
is a big one everyone thinks of a
sequencing laboratory as the big black
hole
of the you know first of all hospitals
already think of laboratories as
as as cost centers and then the
laboratory thinks the sequencing lab is
an even bigger cost center
um but reimbursement
is changing the landscape has been
moving
progressively better year after year
things like lung cancer are reimbursing
almost universally at this point for us
and so you know at scale
these if you you're doing volumes
approaching ours or even higher than
that
the costs per test can be actually
really low um
but this requires large batches
expensive bulky automation and
importantly it requires the thousands of
cases a year right
so if you're a medium sized
or a small size hospital system that
has a costly send out for sequencing
right now
but doesn't have enough samples to
uh to be able to uh
run your own sequencing in-house it's
kind of this weird middle zone
um and so assays that have the ability
to do low batch sizes can have huge
amounts of benefit
so i'm talking about one to four samples
per run but they're currently
right now really expensive uh this is
ideal for lower volume tests that are
still costly to send out
this is a an r in our case we actually
don't do that much ct dna um
we're only the the even in the system
it's only
a few a week and so it's it's been
difficult uh to justify for us to bring
to bring this in-house and so
some of the newer platforms uh that have
the ability
to do this low batch size at a more
efficient
uh rate uh this is the stuff that we're
gonna be bringing on to be able to do
these
uh lower volume tests i think that uh
it's important because
again i the the scenario that i always
end up thinking about
is uh as a hospital that has like three
or four lung cancers
a uh a week and they're being nickeled
and dimed
to get you know they're sending out an
out they're sending out a ross they're
sending out a beer out they're sending
out an egfr
they're sending out all this testing and
they're pla paying for it at client bill
prices right
um and when you add all of that up
that cost once you get past two
three uh uh
different single gene assays the
efficiency of doing
sequencing starts to pass it and if you
have
also that efficiency of the ability to
do low batch sizes
i think that uh being able to bring that
and
internalize that in-house is is
something that's a huge value
not just monetarily for the hospital but
clinically for the patients within it
so uh the reason i say clinically it's
important to do sequencing and
clinically
is a this sort of case study that i'm
going to end with here
um this is a 49 year old man
with metastatic bone and brain non-small
cell lung cancer
he had a biopsy done at an outside
hospital
that was doing exactly what i'm saying
they have relatively small volume
um and so they send out all of their
single gene testing
um and he had egfr sanger done
a braf pcr a pdl-1
ihd that was done and then when they got
to alec and ross for fish
the sample was q and s there was nothing
left and so
the oncologist came uh
had the patient come to cedars for
treatment um and
they actually did a repeat biopsy
because the alkane ross fish was q
s and we did sequencing on it as we do
on all of our lung cancer cases and what
we found was not an alkaros
rearrangement
we actually ended up finding a rare
variant inside of egfr
that was not covered by this anger
sequencing
so this is an egfr kinase domain
duplication essentially what it is is
the
kinase domain so exons 18-25 of the
egfr gene were duplicated it's an
activating mutation it's
relatively rare uh some study says it's
about one percent of all egfr mutations
so say one percent of 15 percent right
of non-small cell lung cancer but i bet
you that that number is actually a
little higher
uh because we haven't been testing for
it uh and we'll probably see that that
rise over time
um importantly it's targetable
uh there are uh uh
there were papers at the time they were
showing some sensitivity therapy and
found him
we we actually ended up having the
patient uh on on
on the third generation t guys those
suburban and they did
amazingly uh their uh tumor melted
there's
this is now two years now um and uh
this is one of those things that would
have never been found
if they if this patient had single
single gene testing only
uh only sequencing will pick up
something like this and the reason is
because uh it's not it's not designed
the single gene tests for egfr are not
designed to be able to pick up these
sort of rearrangements
um and they can't be asked to because
it's so rare
sequencing has the ability to include
essentially
every single rare variant along with
all of the common ones for only a
fraction
slightly higher cost so i think that
understanding that you can have
a cost-efficient molecular laboratory
that is
also clinically beneficial to patients
in 2020
is something that uh that that that can
be
uh done now with some of the new
technologies coming out
so uh these are some of the future
improvements that i think a lot of
pathologists
want to see before they bring in
sequencing in the house
they want to see the ability to have
reduced turnaround time uh
so that their testing can be worked
around said
something like the 14 day rule their
testing can get out relatively quickly
uh batching's flexibility is huge
uh this actually ends up helping with
turnaround time because now instead of
waiting two weeks to fill up a batch a
big batch
you can run something every day or every
other day or what uh
one as soon as you get a sample um and
uh before when this would be cost
prohibitive
if you have new technologies that uh
bring it down
your this becomes something that's
reasonable now
um and then finally i think everybody
wants a simplified laboratory workflow
uh we have consolidated almost all by
doing sequencing you end up
consolidating all of your single gene
tests into those sequencing panels
you don't need to have 10 different qcs
you don't need to have
all the different cap checklists all the
different proficiencies for all your
texts
it's something that really ends up
being beneficial for the lab overall and
provides cost savings that
aren't even seen when you first when you
first look at it
so with that i will take any
questions thank you
thank you dr bill for your time and
presentation today it looks like we
didn't have any questions come in but we
really appreciate your information it
was a great
perspective from the pathologist's point
of view
now to discuss the new world of easy ngs
with the genexis system
i would like to introduce our next
speaker dr andy felton
dr phelp will provide an overview of the
genexa system and the benefits of using
the platform after sars kobe 2 with
minimal hands-on time and reduced and or
furloughed lab staff
andy is currently the vice president of
product management and market
development for the clinical sequence
clinical sequencing division responsible
for the development and launch of all
products
related to iron torn ngs systems andy
began his career at applied biosystems
uk team in 1994
after completing an undergraduate degree
in chemistry at
liverpool university and his phd focused
on peptide fragments and epiterminal
growth factor
at oxford brooks university in 1997 he
moved to corporate headquarters in
california
and entered product management during
this time andy was responsible
for the number a number of product lines
and launches including the launch of the
7 300
7500 and 7500 fast real-time pcr systems
the 3 500 and 3500 dx genetic analyzers
and eventually becoming the director of
capillary electrophoresis business
and he joined iron torrent in june 2010
during its startup phase and subsequent
purchase by life technologies
andy thank you very much for joining us
today
well welcome to the presentation and
thank you very much for joining my
name's andy felton
and today i'm going to be talking about
the iron torrent genexis system really
the first
specimen to report turnkey next
generation sequencing platform
just a quick safe harbor statement
genexis system and its assays for
research use only
the content of this presentation is
based on future potential developments
and is intended to be entirely future
looking in nature
the more official scientific is not
promoting or encouraging any current
diagnostic or clinical use of the
genexis system
or any other research use only products
discussed in this presentation
so the challenges and barriers today are
really shown on this
slide in terms of how to implement next
generation sequencing the clinical
research setting quite often it's a very
slow and complex operation
results can take days to weeks
to be turned around there's generally
been a high level expertise required to
run ngs
and it's often been the case that many
modular workflows
and multiple instrument systems are
required to generate the data
and lastly in terms of the economics and
the actual
tissue requirements for the sample in
general it's been
quite difficult for staff to maintain
their training and hire
and also be able to economically run the
right
batch numbers of samples in particular
for a small number of samples
the labs may often get in the door in a
week
and many of the samples that come
through the door typically have
very small quantities of material
available to them
and with those very small quantities of
material become
quantity not sufficient problems in
other words there isn't enough sample to
generate an actual result
what we've been developing over the last
few years
is a system that aims to solve the
majority if not all of those problems so
all the genexa system as i mentioned
it's the world's
first we believe turnkey fully automated
next generation sequencing platform
that allows you to process from the
biological specimen
and generate a report in a single day
with just
two user touch points and the aim of
this system is really to
allow you to generate next generation
sequence or mutational profiling results
at the same time as your
immunohistochemistry result
and provide the maximum amount of
information to your
clients in terms of the data on
mutational profile of the sample
the system consists of both automated
sample preparation that's the box the
smaller box on the left hand side
and then on the right hand side is a
single what we call integrated sequencer
that
contains library prep sequencing and
analysis
as well as reporting to deliver results
in that single day
it allows you to economically batch the
samples
and is built with the requirements of
fda registration in the future and iso
1345
requirements for both the system and the
consumables
and today what we're going to talk
mainly about is oncology applications
but we have validated both inherited
molecular genetic testing
data as well as reproductive health and
some infectious disease assays as well
so here's an overview of the system as i
mentioned on the left hand side
is uh what's called the iron torrention
nexus purification system that's
currently in development
and available in the early part of 2021
then into that you place your
lysates in the case of an ffpe sample so
there's some offline
preparation work to generate a lysate
from the ffp sample
or you place plasma directly in for a
liquid biopsy alkylation
application or any one of the sample
types you see there
in about four hours for up to 12 ffp
samples
you can prepare both the isolated dna
and rna
or you can run up to six 4ml plasma
samples through the system
the purification system will output both
a working plate
of quantitative nucleic acid so it fully
automates the extraction process
with cartridge based reagents and simple
easy to use
setup about five minutes and then
outputs both a working plate of
quantitative nucleic acid and in the
case of
ffp an archival plate which you can
retain
for future use that working plate then
goes into the
next part of the workflow again with a
simple five minutes of hands-on setup
time
into the iron torrent genexis integrated
sequencer
which performs the steps of library
preparation
uh clonal amplification sequencing and
reporting and what you can see there are
the number of elements
uh the chip itself is brand new on this
platform it uses our
standard ion semiconductor sequencing
chemistries
but the chip in this case is broken up
into four lanes
and each lane has 12 to 15 million reads
and each lane can be addressed
independently so in the case of this
chip
you can see it's about 12 hours for a
single lane on the chip to be run
and depending on which exact protocol
you run
between 18 and up to about 36 hours with
the majority of applications running in
less than 24 hours
on a full chip in terms of the number of
samples
that could be prepared the capability of
the system is up to 32 libraries
per run and i'll break down in the next
slide how that will
interface with the number of samples
that we can run but 32 libraries is the
max that can be generated in a single
run
so it really helps to flexibly
utilize your workflow and then that up
to four different kinds of assays can be
paired in sequence simultaneously in a
single run that's provided they run on
the same
chemistry or have compatible thermal
protocols
and as i said about 32 maximum of 32
library preparations in a single run
the chemistries that we support for
library preparation are our current
ampliseq protocols and our ampliseq hp
based protocols and that covers the vast
majority of
our portfolio of assays both in oncology
inherited disease and infectious disease
majority of them are based on either
apple c core hd
in terms of the number of samples that
breaks down the following way so if you
have a single pool
uh amplicon library for apple seeker
amplistic hd
you can actually run up to 32 samples
if you require a two pool library then
you would be able to run 16 samples or
an eight port
for four the beauty of the system
is that the chip and the reagents can
stay on the instrument for up to two
weeks
so for example if you want to use run a
few samples
in week one you might choose to use lane
one or lane one plus two
and then come back the following week
and then use up
lanes three and four or every other day
you might be using a lane depending on
how your samples
come into the lab so the throughput and
assay flexibility is really maintained
by having
both the chip and strips of reagents
which correspond to the numbers of
samples that you are
coming into the lab in any particular
time frame
in terms of the numbers of samples that
could be run
what you can see on this chart for the a
particular assay type so let's pick
about the fourth assay down the oncoming
precision assay
total nucleic acid so this would be a
liquid biopsy workflow
you can see for a liquid biopsy sample
we can run one
sample per lane so the chip can run up
to a total of four
samples per chip whereas if you take
that same on command precision assay
and run it for ffpe samples the depth of
sequencing requirement isn't
nearly as high so you can run four
samples on a lane or a total of 16
samples on a chip
and there are various assays that you
see there that we have worked out both
the
sample numbers and the turnaround time
for
so looking at the bottom row of the
table the turnaround time for oncoming
precision assay
for the cftna or total nucleic acid
liquid biopsy workflow
is 14 hours for a single lane or
18 hours for a full sample run
and correspondingly for the ffpe that
would be 14 and a half hours for a
single lane of samples
for four samples and just over a day at
27 hours
for 16 samples in a run
in terms of generating the final output
and the final reporting there are really
three pretty simple steps
genexis software automatically generates
a table of variants
and these variants are then filtered and
reviewed and that takes about a minute
takes about a minute for uh to qc the
samples
and then we go on to generate a report
and
uh that takes about five minutes
this is what a report looks like so
end-to-end integration from specimen to
report
on the right hand side you can see uh
the example of a particular
output from a non-small cell lung cancer
ffpe sample
and you can see we are detecting this
particular case a rhet
fusion as well as a pic3
ca mutation so it's a very simple
report you can have it as a single page
report with
all the findings summarized to make it
very easy to use or
a more complex report and it is
customizable depending on the lab's
needs
we have option for integrated analysis
on the instrument
or you can use our cloud ion reporter
version or a separate iron reporter
server
genesis 6.2 software which is our latest
revision contains some really fantastic
features allowing you to for example
here compare
variant reports across samples or across
time in this case you can see that a
particular sample
was queried for variants and you can see
the frequency of those variants
is varying depending on the time a
sample was collected so we can see the
progress of the therapy
as it works on the sample over time
so lastly i'll give you some examples of
our customers who've been using the data
and you're hopefully going to hear more
throughout this presentation this is a
set of research
from our collaborator and now uh
colleague dr jose lewis costa when he
was at the institute of molecular
pathology at the university of porto in
portugal
and he was comparing
a samples between run on his existing
gene studio platform
and his genexis platform and showing the
both
the uniformity of coverage uh the
percent of reads on target
and the amplicon coverage so some basic
metrics in terms of the performance of
amplicon
based sequencing on either the gene
studio genexis platform
in this case it was a postnatal and
prenatal research samples for inherited
disease ample seek based panel and you
can see the
comparable performance between the two
and if you want to look at that
presentation in more detail there's a
link on the slide
secondly we ran a multi-center
study coordinated by dr michael hummel
from the charity
institute of medicine in berlin and you
can see the
results on the right hand slide so in
this case we were comparing
multiple ffpe samples
for concordance between with genexis
and oncoming precision assay against
previously characterized samples using a
variety of different assays
the oncomode focus the alkaline solid
tumor
colon along v2 and also the illuminator
site 170.
and the graph shows you that we have a
very high r squared or correlation
between the data
on all those different assays versus the
oncoming precision assay
and we have both high sensitivity and
specificity
as well as high concordance for those
assays on the genexis
using the oncoming precision assay
an example of some data from one of our
collaborators at the university of basel
in switzerland dr philip german
and in this case uh we were detecting an
alk
fusion with a novel uh uh
technology that's built into the
oncoming precision assay that's called
fusion sync and this allows us to detect
novel fusions
and if you look at the little graph on
the right you can see on the
y-axis the axon and
the blue line indicates the reads
related to the particular fusion event
and the gray
bars are the comparable if there were
no fusion present so you can see here at
above exon 15 or below exon 15 we're
seeing a
significant reduction in the number of
reads we see and
above that you can see the reeds go back
to normal so we're detecting
an arc fusion via this novel imbalance
method
and then concordant to an outbreak apart
fish experiment
and lastly uh dr amanda lowe from the
japan center for cancer research or
foundation for cancer research
compared our genexis oncoming precision
assay
against in liquid biopsy mode
against previously characterized
mutations so i knew the newly diagnosed
with egfr mutations or after therapy
on progressive disease after treatment
with egfr tki inhibitors
and you can see we have a hundred
percent concordance in the detection of
those mutations
and the kinds of mutations uh relative
to the
the previous data so really uh great to
see how concordant that sample set is
we expect to keep continuing the uh
assay development roadmap
uh through this year and into next year
uh
adding additional targets we've already
launched our
sars sarsko v2 assay for whole genome
re-sequencing on the genesis platform
we have just announced our myeloid assay
on the genesis platform for hemato
oncology
we expect to add a bracha one common
bracker assay
around about the end of this year and
we'll be continuing to build out
uh the selection of assays as we go into
2021 beyond
and we also support custom ampliseq or
custom employee hd
assays as well as our oncoming uh
comprehensive assay v3 our oncoming tcr
beta long read assay and our apple seek
on demand portfolio so already a
significant group of assays
and technologies on the genexis platform
that will continue to build as we go
through 21
and 22. thank you for your time
thank you andy for your time and
presentation today it was a great
overview of the genexis platform
and provided excellent insight into its
ease of use and utility and precision
oncology
i would like to remind the audience they
can ask questions in the chat feature
and we do have a few questions that have
come in for you andy
question number one our lab has
currently taken on
sars cov2 testing and we have had to
hire more techs to keep up with the
volumes
but we need to add additional ftes to
start doing oncology research testing
on the genexis and if so how many
so that's a great question thank you um
so the system is designed to be very low
um uh a low amount of hands on time for
the tech so we expect about
you know 10 to 20 minutes of actual
physical setup time for the instrument
and then some time to prepare the
samples so i would say
in most cases it probably doesn't
require an extra
pair of hands to actually operate the
genexis instrument given the amount of
low amount of hands on time to actually
get it set up and running
and then it runs completely
automatically after that
great next question how difficult is it
to bring in the genexis system and what
kind of support
does thermal fission provide yeah that's
another great question
obviously thermal fissure has a pretty
extensive support team
both in our field application scientist
group and specifically for
oncology we have a clinical application
scientist team so these are
groups of scientists who are trained or
have been involved with
laboratory test development in their
past careers
and they are will help you get up and
running
they can help through the process of
getting the instrument to lab uh
answering questions about how you would
validate it
uh within your own facility and then
uh assisting in uh
the process to get the assay up and
running so there's an extensive support
team both on the application side as
well as the service side
uh to get you up and running we also
have field bioinformatics scientists who
can answer questions
on the data itself
great thank you and we did have another
question come in as you were
answering that one is opa testing both
rna and dna and plasma if this is the
case how do you stabilize the cell-free
rna in plasma
or which tubes are currently the best
for cell-free dna and cell-free rna
variants to apply ngs
i hope that made sense yeah no that's a
that's a very good question
um so yes uh oncoming precision assay
detects both rna
and dna and plasma we are detecting gene
fusion events
um in terms of stabilizing the the blood
sample itself usually we recommend if it
either an edta or a strect tube
in the case of an edta tube
we recommend that the tube is spun down
as quickly as possible after draw
and then the sample is
run usually within 24 hours
with streck stabilized tubes obviously
you get a little more time but generally
a quicker is better
in most cases i think that covers the
question
yeah great great answer okay thank you
again andy i appreciate the presentation
and uh
and the support there on the questions
now for financial and operational
impacts for implementing the nexus
system in your lab
i would like to introduce mr kevin
kawachi kevin will discuss the ease of
use of the instrumentation
specimen to report testing without the
need for bioinformatics expertise
minimal hands-on time needed and
financial benefits of bringing ngs
in-house kevin is currently the
associate director of the molecular
pathology and cytogenetics laboratories
at cedars-sinai medical center
department of pathology and laboratory
medicine kevin has worked at
cedars-sinai for more than 30 years as a
clinical laboratory scientist
he has a specialist certification in
immunology from the asap and received
his master's in public health from ucla
kevin has been involved with molecular
testing for more than 20 years
his current role is to oversee
operations and testing in the molecular
pathology and cytogenetics laboratories
kevin thank you for joining us today
hello i'm kevin kawachi i'm the
associate director of cyber genetics and
molecular pathology
at cedars-sinai medical center in los
angeles today i'll be talking about the
financial and operational impact of the
geneticist
for in-house genetic profiling
um here's the standard disclaimer
i'd like to talk a little bit about the
cedarsoni molecular pathology laboratory
we
are a small to medium-sized molecular
pathology hospital laboratory
and we do approximately 22 000 samples a
year
but we have now taken on code testing
which has more than
uh quadrupled our volume
to close to more than north of
150 000 samples a year
we do a mixed variety of
testing within our molecular laboratory
we do some viral
viral testing including cov2 testing
we do some genetic testing as well as
oncology testing including both
hematologic and solid tumor testing
and we also perform sequencing
on both tumor and myeloid samples
we currently are doing on tumor samples
approximately
900 samples per year and myeloid
approximately
200 a year so our volume is close to
1200
a year 11 to 1200 a year in testing and
it continues to increase
so a little bit on the thermal fissure
genexis system
and what i'm going to talk a little bit
about
is what our considerations in the
laboratory
for acquiring a new piece of
instrumentation
or what we what we consider when we are
looking to bring in a test
uh and the first part will be a little
bit on testing availability
what is available on the platform on in
any individual test as well as some
operational efficiencies what is it
going to bring to the laboratory
relative to the you know operational
operational standpoint as well as you
know what is
the benefit to cost uh of performing
this test you know from the perspective
of labor
or you know uh changing your how it's
going to change your test menu
and addition to that we're going to take
a look at we'd like to look at
bioinformatics
and you know what type of support you
get for instrumentation i think
within the laboratory that is a big
concern and then just what the overall
workflow
impact or changes would be in looking at
the genetic geneticist system
okay so for testing availability we look
at as we're looking at the genexis
system we look at
some you know what are the primary
considerations for bringing
in this instrument and for us it was the
oncoming precision assay
and and what caught our eye on this
assay was the amount of
nucleic acid input that is required for
this assay
as well as the turnaround time and and
as well as the sample types that can be
used both the ffp
and circulating tumor dna
secondary considerations obviously you
don't buy an instrument for just one
test
is what can we add to the our menu uh in
addition to the alkaline precision assay
and that would be
uh tcr beta as well as a comprehensive
and into that the myeloid assay so those
are all considerations that we had
once for future uh growth on the
instrumentation
so first we'll look at a little bit on
operational efficiency
i think uh just for comparison's sake i
have
um some things on what we we've been
doing here at cedar sinai
um over the past six years and we
started out with
a 50 gene cancer hotspot panel
using the pgm platform
back when we first started it was about
14 hours of technologists hands-on time
over two and a half days a significant
amount of time
to be used to do the test but also the
challenge of having multiple
technologists do this test and um
getting the consistency that you would
be interested in getting
on on an assay in 2016
we moved to the 50 gene cancer hot spot
panel
using the ion chef and the s5 sequencer
that was a significant change for us
in that we were able to now automate
some of the processes
and allow free up a technologist to
um to be able to other testing
and reduce the labor on the test so at
this point it was about
three hours of technologies hands-on
time over two and a half days
and that was the limiting factors back
then what were the
number of um the number of chefs
and the sequencing time was a little bit
longer in 2018 we brought on the
alkamine comprehensive assay
using iron chef and s5 sequencers
and this is about the same three and a
half hours of time on
hands-on time over about a day and a day
and a quarter
about 30 hours and the game changer here
was that we were able to acquire
five ion shafts and two s5 primes
to be able to uh perform and optimize
the workflow
for for the assay create being able to
create
multiple libraries at the same time as
well as templating
so this was uh this is pretty much the
most efficient that we've been
and so when we started to look at the
genexis system we say well what
what would that change and what's going
to change and if we can reduce those
that time with the three hours to you
know a third of that
or an hour or less than an hour that is
that's
you know that's efficiency that we would
look at
um also the the assay completion time
was significantly less than our current
assay
in 16 to 21 hours and i think
part of in the in the laboratory world
i believe that you know scheduling is
the most challenging part of
performing test testing in that you have
to be able to
uh schedule the people and they also
have to have days off so having a
flexible schedule
is one of the more important things from
the operational efficiency standpoint
okay i think i'll talk a little bit
about cost analysis
or what goes into the cost evaluation
when you get an instrument and relative
to the genexis
we wanted to uh take a look at
what is single gene testing versus
the oncoming precision assay and
yet the single gene testing paradigm has
been in place for
many many years and the need for those
single genes
is very important and that has been the
standard within
within the laboratory but and the reason
for that standard is that the
there is a need for fast turnaround time
for those
genes of interest uh in able to
address this in performing the tests we
think that the
alkali precision assay on the genexis
may be that that solution
and that it can perform testing on a
single gene
and allow us to not have to
run multiple runs of of single gene
tests per week
single gene testing also has had a
significant
impact on the technology's time and cost
for the individual
assays in addition to the higher amount
of nucleic acid that is required to do
single multiple single gene tests
uh moving on to an ngs platform
and the alkaline precision assay this
will allow
for evaluation of multiple genes
simultaneously
and this is the positive aspect of doing
you know doing sequencing
a turnaround time does vary depending on
the size of the platform the testing
that's being being done as well as
bioinformatics and the analysis portion
of the assay so by consolidating
the gene content it does reduce the cost
per gene relative to doing individual
gene testing
relative to the oncoming precision assay
we
feel that it will show a reduction in
labor
and turnaround time to on the order of
single gene testing
with an output of multiple genes
so a little bit on bioinformatics and
support
bioinformatics is an area that is
there is an increasing focus on
bioinformatics
has become you know as important if not
more important than the wet
bench processes in sequencing
and with bioinformatic pipelines there's
a huge variation
in how they are constructed whether
they're built
on a standard platform or built in-house
and what variants are called what
annotations are done
and what reports are generated
the appeal for the genexis system is
that it has a
consolidated solution for a lot while
also allowing
access of the raw data for evaluation
of you know what the calls are and what
calls are made versus what calls that
are not made
relative to support support when you
purchase
an assay or an instrument is probably
the most key component
it is important for the success of
continued operation to have
support from both the vendor
as well as on the assay
itself so the advantages to having a
unique vendor would be
we were able to optimize the assay on
the platform
with the assistance of the vendor also
from the perspective
of troubleshooting when there are
problems with the assay
if you are using if you're not using
this compatible vendor or the same
vendor
you often run into difficulties in
troubleshooting
your assay because it's hard to
determine whether it is the acid
performance or it's the instrument
performance and i think
the most important part is also from the
from the support
perspective is what type of service or
repair do you get
from that vendor and by having all of
these things consolidated on one
platform both the assay and the
instrument
it gives us the ability to be able to
call and both
troubleshoot and if it is a service
related thing have somebody come out and
fix that the instrument as well
so with the genexis
what impact would it have on the
laboratory in the molecular pathology
lab
and so what we we're seeing is that
we're hoping to use this
to expand our offerings with a
smaller sequencing panel this would be
looked at as a supplement to a larger
panel
and as we all know that the panels are
increasing
in the number of genes but along with
that we also know that
it does increase the turnaround time
when you increase the genes so
having the offerings of a smaller
sequencing panel really takes us back to
what we were doing
about five or six years ago at
cedars-sinai and that we took
our 50 gene panel and we made we made
even
smaller sub-panels that were
more tailored to certain types of
tumors and so and and the second piece
is that the scheduling of the genexis
runs
will be flexible and flexibility as i
said earlier in the laboratory is key
because
of staffing is highly variable p your
staffing is not 24 7
and seven days a week and we have to be
able to be flexible and
to customize the days that the runs
are set up um having some having a
platform that
is fully optimal automated
will allow the technologists to have
minimal hands-on time
and that is a key component to the
uh to the genexis system uh currently we
have to have a technology
technologist available uh throughout the
day
even though the hands on time may be
mult they have to be available
multiple times a day on multiple
sequential days to get the
sequencing run completed
of having a flexible batch size is
something that also was very
interesting for us and that we would be
able to
run smaller number of samples and mix
the type of samples that we run
over a week or two week period allowing
us
to adjust to the incoming sample
volumes so overall we think that the
genexis system would be very useful
in addition to genetic profiling within
the
molecular pathology lab at cedar sinai
thank you are there any questions
thank you kevin for your time and
presentation today it was a very
insightful perspective and important
considerations
when deciding to bring ngs testing into
your lab and we do have a few questions
from the audience
question number one you mentioned that
your lab volume quadrupled with the
addition of sars kobe 2 testing
how will the genexis workflow fit in
with your lab and help your current
staffing needs
um so we believe that the genexis
platform will decrease the technologies
time significantly allowing us to
perform
additional testing including coded
testing
the tech time saved you know really is
from you know preparing the instrument
and reagents
from both the um from library
to templating and from templating to
sequencing
there is of the possibility of saving
that tech time
and freeing them up to not have to
perform testing
you know at specific times during the
day so this
will have a positive impact to the lab
great thank you question number two
besides being able to interrogate more
genes at a time with ngs testing over
single gene testing
reducing the cost per gene what were
other financial considerations in
deciding to bring
in the genexis um
i believe the the versatility of batch
size is probably the key
um key thing for the laboratory
um our current sequencing workflow
requires a set number
of samples per chip and as
if those if you do not reach that set
number of samples the price
significantly increases um the genexis
you know with the gx5 chip and the four
lanes will allow us
a little bit more flexibility um
having smaller batch sizes will also um
also allow us to
manage our turnaround time a little bit
more effectively
great thank you and thanks again for
your time and presentation today
that was definitely helpful information
if we did not get your question it will
be saved and we will get back to you
individually with response and the
presentation will be available on demand
with that this concludes our on combined
education day changing the precision
oncology research paradigm
i would like to thank dr eric bale dr
andy felton
and mr kevin kawachi for sharing their
valuable presentations with us today
we would like to thank you all in
attendance for your participation in
today's program
and remind you to please complete the
conclusion survey thanks again and enjoy
the rest of your week